sometimes it's useful to have a number
which has lots of factors like the
number 12 which can be divided by 2 and
3 and 4 and 6 and 12 itself we find
these things useful sometimes the
ancient greek philosopher plato ah he
thought the best choice for something
like this was the number
5040. he thought this was the best
choice because it had loads of divisors
lots of factors so one divide into it
obviously two divide three four five
six seven divide eight divide nine
divide ten divide so all the numbers up
to ten divide
12 divides into it as well and it's got
60 divisors all together so plato was
thinking this is the best number you
could have for like say a city if you
had a the population of a city was 5004
you could divide that up into all kinds
of different groups if you wanted to
divide up the land then you would divide
it up into units of 5040. 5040 lots of
divisors plus
it has more divisors than all the
numbers less than 5040. we now call this
a highly composite number it's like an
antiprime it's like yeah it's like an
anti-prime okay yeah it's the most
divisible number lots of divisors uh in
fact the first guy who really properly
studied this was the famous indian
mathematician ramanujan did it about 100
years ago
let's take a look at properties of
highly composite numbers anti-prime
numbers
i don't think it's going to catch on
brady i think you're 100 years too late
for that so the definition of a highly
composite number
is one that has more divisors
factors if you want to call it factors
more divisors than any number smaller
than it
there let's let's just run through the
numbers and let's find some so these are
like these are always like the previous
title yeah exactly uh how many devices
for one it's just one
so two it's a prime so like primes do um
the only things that divide primes are
one and itself it has two divisors
primes have two divisors so three would
be the same it has two divisors four now
four is going to be different it can
divide by one
two and four so it has three divisors
and hey
this has more divisors than the others
before it so now this is the current
winner this is the highly composite
number so far let's see what five does
well five's a prime uh so
five
loses all right way down there two four
still the title yeah four still winning
but then six comes along and oh dear six
it can be right by one two
three and six four divisors and now six
is ahead of the game we keep going well
seven ah no seven's no good so prime it
has two divisors eight uh does eight do
any better so we can divide by one
two
four
uh eight
uh four divisors and it's not better
than six then
so four divisors no it hasn't won
anything
and nine has three devices so it's uh
one three and nine
ten has four devices
11 prime two devices 12
has six divisors because i sell i told
you 12 is one of these numbers that have
lots of things that divide into it one
two three four six and 12. so that has
six divisors 12 is really good really up
there and then
so on so yeah well let's have a look at
the title holders then okay highly
composite numbers let's write out the
sequence one you're correct one is there
two is there
four
six
twelve
and if you carry on 24 36 48 60 60 is a
good number that's why we have 16
minutes in an hour 60 seconds 120 180
360 is there like degrees in a circle
lots of things divide into 360. it's a
good number to do 720 and 840 and so on
right and they carry on like that
so these are this is our sequence of
highly composite numbers it's a very
important theorem in maths called the
fundamental theorem of arithmetic if you
want its fancy name it means
all
positive whole numbers can be written as
a product of primes by multiplying prime
numbers together this is why primes are
important there are building blocks for
other numbers there are atoms for other
numbers so all other numbers can be
written
like this if you had a number
you'd have
you'd have primes let's just call them
prime one
to a power
prime two to some power
prime three
to some power and that would go up and
then it would end at some point you'd
have to last prime here prime k
to
some power let's do an example so if you
had the number 30 it's built up from
primes it's 2 times 3 times 5. primes
that divide 30 has to be either 2 3 or 5
doesn't divide yeah so if i had if i do
another example if i had 550
it'd be 2 times 5 squared times 11. 3
doesn't divide into it 7 doesn't divide
into it 19
cannot divide into this number
and now if you want to do if you want to
look at the factors
you just use that idea repeatedly so the
factors are the primes that divide into
it
repeatedly so i could divide this by 25
because i can divide by 5 and then 5
again
or if i want to divide by 10 i can
divide it by 2 and then divide by 5. so
the factors are just all the possible
combinations or permutations of these
prime atoms that you've been given to
work with
they would all look like this all the
factors would look like this it'd be the
same primes should be your p1 and p2 and
p3
up to pk
you would have powers here
let's call them b1 and b2 b3
just these powers would be 0 or one or
two or three or up to and including
the final thing so anything less
than what i've called a up here
now those are your factors so how many
factors are there just to show you how
many factors there are then the factors
of a number let's call it n or the
divisors of n
is um well how many choices do i get for
these powers and it's this
it could be zero one two three four
anything up to a one
so it'd be uh a one plus one
multiply by how many choices for this
second prime power
zero one two three four anything up to a
two
that's uh one plus a two
choices
you just do the same thing for each of
these prime powers
so that would go up to the last one
which is a k plus one and that's how
many divisors though i'll do an example
with these shall i so if i do about 30
if i look for the divisors of 30
i can use this little formula but look
all the powers are just one how many
choices would i have for each of these
powers there's two choices there
two for that one two for that one so all
the powers are one
and this is going to be two times two
times 2 which is 8
and there are 8 divisors of 30.
and if i did it for 550 slightly
different because i've got this square
in it
so how many choices here for the first
prime power if there's two and so i
would have 12
factors of 550. so we've seen how to
work out
divisors and we should just check 5040
it's meant to be great 5040 let's see
how many divisors that has
if you broke it down into primes then
it's going to look like this
it's 2 to the power 4 multiplied by 3
squared
multiplied by 5
multiplied by 7.
so let's look at that divider formula
so we want divisors of 5040.
we can use the powers to help us work
that out so it's going to be
by 3 by 2
by two and that's going to be 60. so
there are 60 divisors of 5040 which is
greater
than the number smaller than 5040. that
makes it highly composite 100 years ago
ramanujan started studying these and he
noticed three properties that highly
composite numbers have to have
which i'll i'll show you now they're not
too difficult to understand the first
property is the primes of the
factorization of our highly composite
number have to be consecutive primes i
mean look that's what happened here you
look at 5040
they were they were consecutive primes
they were 2 3
5 and 7. now if you look at 550 just to
compare it with something where it
doesn't work that wasn't consecutive
primes
that was
by
5 squared by 11.
now i know
that this is not a highly composite
number because i could replace this 11
for one of the missing primes i could
replace it for seven
and it would be a smaller number but
with the same number of divisors same
number of factors so it's not going to
be highly composite or the best choice
would be if i picked a number which had
consecutive primes so if i picked i'm
going to use the same powers though like
they are there so i'm going to use this
2 by 3 squared by five yeah that's
better that has consecutive primes it's
a much smaller number it's 90
but 90 we can see has the same number of
divisors as 550 so this is a much better
choice than 550 so it failed so yes if
you've got a highly composite number the
primes are consecutive that's that's
kind of nice the second thing
reminiscent noticed is the powers in
their prime factorization they have to
be weakly decreasing they have to be
going down like this so you can see it
here with 540. look four
two one and one so they're going weekly
down so they're not increasing uh but it
didn't happen here with my 550 it didn't
happen here with my 90 either i tell you
why because i could make a better choice
if i swapped the powers around and if i
put them in a decreasing order it would
look like this i could have a 2
squared multiply by 3 multiplied by 5.
so it's the same powers
but in a decreasing order that makes the
number smaller
so why is that as 60.
so now you've got 60 there it has the
same number of divisors
and hey this is a much better choice
than 90 and in fact
60 there is a highly composite number
the third thing maminujan noticed was
these highly composite numbers uh all
end
with uh
with one as the last power
so they always end up with a single
prime there at the end and so it doesn't
end with a square at the end there's
actually a couple of exceptions for that
there are two exceptions these are
highly composite numbers that break that
rule
four
is a highly composite number and that's
two squared
and the other number is 36
which is a 2 squared
by 3 squared what ramanujan showed is
that highly composite numbers have to
end with a prime that has a power 1 or 2
has these two exceptions here and
everything else they all end with the
one
uh with their prime power at the end
oh that's less obvious less obvious than
the other facts i showed you that took
some while to prove
but it's another
necessary condition for a highly
composite number
in addition to our usual supporters we'd
like to thank audible.com for supporting
this video if you have to cover a few
miles in planes or trains or automobiles
one of the best ways to pass the time is
listening to audiobooks so while you
watch me driving here from bristol to
nottingham let me tell you about
audible.com they've got a huge range of
titles a great app and a good offer for
new customers but before i tell you
about that first a recommendation and
i'm going to suggest airframe by michael
crichton it deals with a topic i always
find fascinating that is air crash
investigations maybe not one to listen
to on a plane if you're a nervous flyer
but definitely worth your time now
audible are offering a free 30-day trial
of their service which includes your
first book if you go to audible.com
numberfile
using that url will mean they know you
came from here that address again
audible.com numberphile for the free
trial eye is audible i think they're
well worth a look and i'd like to thank
them again for supporting this number
file video
makes it very anti-prime
stop trying to make antiprime a thing
stop trying to make fetch your thing